Traduttore: Giulia Marcassoli
Revisore: Sofia Ramundo
(Applausi)
Vorrei iniziare con una domanda.
Per trovare grandi quantità di oro,
dove lo andreste a cercare?
Probabilmente molti di voi risponderanno:
"Forse la cosa migliore da fare
è andarlo a cercare in qualche miniera".
Bisogna rimboccarsi le maniche,
mettersi a scavare nel buio
e con una buona dose di fortuna
troveremo l'oro.
Ora io non posso definirmi un minatore,
visto che non ho mai preso in mano
un piccone.
Non sono neanche mai stato in una miniera.
Eppure, sappiate che
con un gruppo di miei colleghi,
provenienti un po' da tutto il mondo,
proprio cercando nel buio,
abbiamo localizzato il più grande
giacimento di oro mai scoperto.
Una riserva pari a qualcosa come
centomila miliardi di miliardi
di tonnellate.
Grammo più,
grammo meno.
Se lo mettessimo tutto sul mercato,
l'oro sarebbe così abbondante da arrivare
a costare molto meno dell'acqua.
Come è possibile?
Ma facciamo prima un passo indietro.
In realtà io non sono qui per parlare
di spedizioni leggendarie
tra le viscere della terra.
Io sono qui per parlare di
esplorazione del cosmo, di astrofisica.
In particolare di qualcosa che,
almeno per noi ricercatori,
è ben più prezioso dell'oro:
ovvero un tipo di stelle
o corpi celesti piuttosto particolari,
chiamati stelle di neutroni,
che sono anche le protagoniste
di una recente scoperta
estremamente importante.
Le stelle di neutroni, in un certo senso,
nascono dalla morte di una stella
di grande massa.
Queste stelle concludono la loro vita
in modo violento,
con un'esplosione violenta
che è nota come supernova.
Forse avete sentito questo nome.
È un fenomeno davvero spettacolare
che osserviamo di tanto in tanto.
Cosa succede?
Quando arriva la fine, cioè quando
il combustibile nucleare si esaurisce,
il nucleo di queste stelle massive
non sopporta più il proprio peso,
inizia a contrarsi,
inizia a collassare verso il centro,
occupando un volume sempre più piccolo
e acquistando densità altissime.
A meno che la massa non sia troppo alta,
- nel qual caso si va a formare subito
un buco nero, non è il nostro caso -
questa contrazione a un certo punto
si arresta improvvisamente
a causa di una nuova forma di pressione,
che interviene quando le particelle,
in questo caso i neutroni,
sono costretti a stare troppo vicini
gli uni agli altri
e quindi tendono a respingersi,
resistono.
Questo arresta la contrazione
in modo improvviso
e questo produce un effetto di rimbalzo
per cui tutto il resto della stella
viene sparato via,
anche con l'aiuto
- io non posso entrare nei dettagli,
ma per essere corretti -
con l'aiuto della spinta dell'emissione
di neutrini dal nucleo.
Non voglio entrare in questi dettagli.
In poche parole,
abbiamo una tremenda esplosione.
E questo fenomeno esplosivo
è appunto la nostra supernova,
mentre l'oggetto compatto
che rimane al centro,
che praticamente sarebbe
il nucleo originario
della stella appena esplosa,
è la nostra stella di neutroni.
Il nome deriva dal fatto che,
a queste densità così alte,
possiamo aspettarci che la materia
sia composta principalmente di neutroni.
Come scala di massa e compattezza è un po'
come concentrare tutto il nostro sole
entro una sferetta di appena 20-30 km,
cioè meno della distanza
tra Padova e Rovigo.
E questo porta a delle densità
spettacolari, che potete immaginare,
che addirittura superano
la densità dei nuclei atomici.
Per dare, diciamo, un controesempio
un po' più tangibile,
un cucchiaio di questa materia
peserebbe circa un miliardo di tonnellate,
cioè più o meno quanto il monte Everest.
Le densità che si raggiungono
in questi oggetti sono così alte
che il comportamento della materia
e le stesse forze fisiche,
le stesse forze fondamentali,
sono in realtà sconosciute
e non c'è modo
di riprodurre queste condizioni
in un laboratorio sulla Terra.
In un certo senso le stelle di neutroni
sono il nostro laboratorio,
grazie al quale
abbiamo l'opportunità unica
di studiare il comportamento della materia
e più in generale le leggi della fisica
in queste condizioni estreme.
Questo è il motivo per cui
le stelle di neutroni sono oggetti
così interessanti e così preziosi.
Pensate a cosa può succedere
se due stelle di neutroni
arrivano a interagire fra di loro.
Come le altre stelle, anche questi oggetti
possono trovarsi in un sistema binario,
quindi trovarsi a orbitare uno
intorno all'altro a una certa distanza.
Qui interviene
un altro effetto fondamentale,
che è l'emissione di onde gravitazionali,
di cui forse avrete sentito parlare
negli ultimi anni.
Come ci insegnano a scuola, la gravità
si manifesta come una forza
che attrae le masse tra di loro.
Ma se una massa si sposta,
questo cambiamento,
l'informazione che è cambiato qualcosa,
non si propaga all'istante in tutto
il resto dello spazio circostante,
ma si propaga come un'onda
nello spazio e nel tempo
e lo fa anche a una velocità ben precisa,
che è la velocità della luce.
Questo lo sappiamo grazie alla teoria
della relatività di Einstein.
Come analogia visiva,
pensate di gettare il sasso nell'acqua.
Questo genera delle onde
che trasportano con sé l'informazione
che a un certo punto
è successo qualcosa al centro,
c'è stata una perturbazione.
Se delle masse si spostano, cambiano,
queste generano onde gravitazionali,
ovvero rimodulazioni e riconfigurazioni
della forza di gravità
percepita alle varie distanze
per effetto di questo cambiamento.
Per esempio, se io muovo la mano,
voi potreste percepire,
in realtà è impercettibile,
una variazione dell'attrazione di gravità
dovuta alla mia mano
che ha cambiato posizione.
Ma non la sentirete all'istante.
Per esempio, chi si trova a 300 metri
la sentirà solo dopo un microsecondo,
che è il tempo di propagazione
dell'onda gravitazionale
che ho generato con il mio spostamento.
Le onde gravitazionali,
come le onde acustiche e le onde radio,
sono tutte conseguenza del fatto che
l'informazione non si sta propagando
all'istante, ma c'è una velocità limite.
Tutti questi tipi di onde,
oltre all'informazione,
trasportano energia,
che viene persa, quindi spesa,
dalla sorgente.
Nel caso di due stelle di neutroni,
in un sistema binario,
queste modificano periodicamente
quello che chiamiamo
il campo gravitazionale
in una maniera fortissima,
ed emettono tantissima energia
in onde gravitazionali.
Visto che l'energia è sottratta
dal moto orbitale,
l'effetto è che gradualmente i due oggetti
perdono, noi diciamo,
il momento angolare,
i due oggetti
si trovano sempre più vicini.
Questo è un sistema
che può evolvere nello stesso modo
per milioni di anni o anche molto di più.
Quando finalmente arriviamo
al punto in cui
le due stelle si toccano,
o meglio si scontrano,
per poi fondersi in un unico oggetto.
E qui avviene il bello,
perché, potete immaginare,
qui si scatena l'inferno, potremmo dire.
Abbiamo delle energie, coinvolte
in questo scontro, straordinarie,
pazzesche,e oltre alle onde gravitazionali
possiamo aspettarci di vedere
anche tantissime emissioni di luce
in tutte le sue forme:
tutto lo spettro elettromagnetico
con raggi gamma, raggi X,
onde radio, luce ultravioletta,
visibile, infrarossa.
Una specie di spettacolo pirotecnico
del cosmo.
Per decenni, chi studia queste cose
a livello teorico, tra cui anche io,
si è interrogato su quali tipi di
emissioni luminose poteva aspettarsi
in concomitanza di questo evento.
Due in particolare sono molto rilevanti.
La prima sono i gamma ray burst:
lampi di raggi gamma luminosissimi
di breve durata,
che in realtà osserviamo ormai
a centinaia ogni anno
e che provengono da galassie lontane.
Questi sono generati
da potenti getti d'energia,
la cui sorgente deve essere per forza
ultracompatta e a rotazione molto rapida.
Guarda caso, le caratteristiche
del nostro oggetto,
risultato della fusione delle due stelle,
sono proprio: ultracompatto
e a rotazione molto rapida.
Quindi è un candidato
per produrre questi eventi.
Numero due: la kilonova.
Questo in realtà è stato predetto
a livello teorico
a partire da questo fatto:
le altissime temperature
e le altissime concentrazioni di neutroni
che si ritrovano in questo scontro
possono accendere un nuovo tipo
di reazioni nucleari chiamato processi R,
che sono responsabili della produzione,
della sintetizzazione
degli elementi più pesanti.
Così pesanti che non li troviamo neanche
al centro di stelle come il sole,
per esempio.
Fra questi elementi c'è anche l'oro,
così come il platino
e così via fino all'uranio.
Possiamo aspettarci
che parte del materiale
che nella violenza dello scontro
viene espulso,
sia in effetti composto
da questi elementi molto pesanti.
Come facciamo a verificarlo?
Questi elementi sono anche radioattivi,
e il loro naturale decadimento
riscalda il materiale stesso
e lo illumina producendo questo segnale
che è chiamato kilonova.
Se vediamo questo segnale,
sappiamo che c'è stata la produzione
di elementi pesanti.
In questo sistema quindi abbiamo
vari pezzi di un puzzle:
abbiamo le onde gravitazionali,
i gamma ray burst, kilonova e altro.
Sono tutti importanti,
e portano informazioni molto preziose
presi singolarmente,
ma per un quadro completo
dobbiamo metterli insieme tutti quanti.
Questo è un caso perfetto
per la cosiddetta
astrofisica multimessaggera,
cioè basata su diversi
canali di osservazione indipendenti,
in questo caso luce
e onde gravitazionali.
Lo scontro di due stelle di neutroni
è sempre stato considerato
la sorgente multimessaggera
per eccellenza,
il tipo di evento più promettente
in quello che è di fatto
un nuovo modo di fare astrofisica.
Ebbene, il 17 agosto 2017,
cioè un paio di anni fa,
per la prima volta abbiamo visto,
detectato, percepito, rivelato
uno di questi scontri cosmici
tra due stelle di neutroni,
avvenuto a 130 milioni di anni luce
di distanza,
che vuol dire anche
130 milioni di anni fa,
quando sulla Terra c'erano i dinosauri.
I segnali prodotti hanno viaggiato
per tutto questo tempo indisturbati
per arrivare poi finalmente da noi.
L'immagine che vi faccio vedere adesso
è probabilmente la più bella immagine,
una vera immagine di questo evento,
presa dal telescopio Hubble.
Qui vediamo la galassia
che ha ospitato il nostro scontro cosmico
e il puntino luminoso in alto a sinistra,
quello arancione,
lì è dove lo scontro è avvenuto,
e quella luce arancione è proprio la luce
della kilonova di cui ho parlato prima.
Devo ammettere che anche per noi
che facciamo questo lavoro
e non ci possiamo stupire
più di tanto di alcune cose,
vedere quest'immagine così chiaramente,
vedere la kilonova con i nostri occhi
è stato molto emozionante.
La campagna osservativa per seguire
quest'evento è stata senza precedenti.
Ha combinato insieme
i rivelatori di onde gravitazionali,
che sono Ligo negli Stati Uniti,
Virgo in Italia
- uno dei tre che sono al momento attivi
è proprio in Italia, vicino Pisa -
e tutta la potenza di fuoco
su scala mondiale
in termini dei migliori telescopi da Terra
e dallo spazio anche in tutte le bande,
quindi alta energia, X, gamma,
i radiotelescopi, tutto quanto.
Ci è andata anche bene, perché
non solo abbiamo visto quest'evento,
ma in un colpo solo abbiamo catturato
tutti gli elementi principali
che da decenni speravamo
di poter osservare e poter studiare
e abbiamo imparato moltissimo.
Prima di tutto questi eventi esistono.
Capitano con una certa frequenza,
che possiamo stimare
e anche da un solo evento
possiamo iniziare a farci un'idea.
Abbiamo visto un lampo di raggi gamma
provenire da lì,
quindi abbiamo confermato
ciò che sospettavamo,
cioè che questi lampi possono essere
prodotti da questi scontri cosmici.
Indirettamente abbiamo capito
qualcosa in più
sul comportamento della materia
a queste densità altissime
perché questo ha un effetto sulla forma
dell'onda gravitazionale,
sul materiale che viene espulso, etc.
Non ultimo, abbiamo visto la kilonova,
quindi abbiamo confermato
la produzione di elementi pesanti
in questi sistemi,
trovandone anche molti di più
di quelli che ci aspettavamo.
Per esempio, tornando all'oro,
si stima che questo evento abbia prodotto
l'equivalente in oro
di qualcosa come dieci volte,
se non cento volte,
la massa del nostro pianeta.
Questo è il centomila miliardi di miliardi
di tonnellate di cui parlavo all'inizio.
Al di là di questo numero spettacolare,
la cosa veramente importante
a livello scientifico
è che tutti gli elementi pesanti,
anche quelli che abbiamo sulla Terra
dall'oro in poi,
vengono anche e forse in gran parte
dallo scontro di stelle di neutroni
avvenuto in passato nella nostra galassia.
Quindi c'è una certa probabilità che l'oro
che costituisce i nostri gioielli
sia stato prodotto in questo modo qui.
Chiudo sull'evento facendovi
vedere questo filmato
che riassume in modo artistico
le varie fasi:
l'emissione di onde gravitazionali,
le ultime orbite,
lo scontro e la produzione del getto
che poi porterà al lampo di raggi gamma,
subito dopo l'illuminazione
di questo materiale espulso,
la kilonova, l'illuminazione radioattiva,
e infine ulteriore radiazione
che è prodotta dal fatto
che questo oggetto
si sta propagando nel mezzo interstellare,
e quindi il fronte di questo oggetto
continua a illuminarsi.
Con questo primo fondamentale evento
abbiamo aperto
l'astrofisica multimessaggera.
È un nuovo capitolo della scienza
che sicuramente nei prossimi anni
porterà tante sorprese.
Una scoperta scientifica di tale portata,
che sicuramente è la più importante a cui
io abbia avuto la fortuna di partecipare,
offre un ottimo esempio
di come osservando il cielo
possa capitarci
di vedere cose straordinarie.
Da una parte questo ci permette,
anzi ci costringe, in qualche modo,
a uscire dai limiti
della nostra stessa immaginazione.
L'universo fa quello che vuole
e lo vediamo in tutta la sua gloria
e in tutta la sua complessità.
Dall'altra,
guardando questi fenomeni molto lontani,
possiamo in realtà imparare
qualcosa di nuovo sulle leggi della natura
e del mondo in cui viviamo,
anche e soprattutto in regimi,
quindi condizioni,
che non siamo in grado di riprodurre
con esperimenti terrestri.
Tutto questo è possibile
solo se abbiamo la capacità
di osservare i vari fenomeni
con i nostri strumenti sempre più potenti,
ma anche e soprattutto se abbiamo
la capacità di capirli, interpretarli,
trasformando un mucchio
di segnali complicati
in una descrizione coerente.
In una frase, questo è il senso
di fare astrofisica.
La storia dell'umanità è fatta
di curiosità ed è fatta di scoperte,
alcune delle quali nate proprio
dal nostro impulso naturale
di alzare gli occhi al cielo notturno
e cercare di spiegarne le meraviglie.
Data questa nostra natura,
credo che lo sviluppo della scienza,
e dell'astrofisica in particolare,
sia stato semplicemente inevitabile
e sono convinto che
dal nostro piccolo angolo di universo
continueremo sempre a esplorare,
a conoscere e a goderci lo spettacolo.
Grazie.
(Applausi)